[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
au menu justement avait on va parler
d'alimentation avec le festival in cité
dont le thème est à table on va parler
aussi de religion va parler de cette
politique avec lionel bah c'est pas
bonjour vous êtes le directeur du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
vous êtes le concepteur le créateur et
organisateur de ce festival qui
s'appelle in cité qui a lieu à partir du
16 mars
16 23 mars prochain dans notre mars et
qui est dont le thème cette année c'est
à table
1 qu'est ce que est ce que est ce que
nous sommes ce que nous mangeons c'est
une des questions mans avec d'autres
d'autres sujets avec sophie mclaughlin
bonjour vous êtes de l'institut sapiens
alors en amont l'institut sapiens alors
si tu sais bien c'est un set une fintec
française la première team tech
française on réfléchit en toute modestie
à la nouvelle place de l'humain dans la
révolution numérique qui a déjà commencé
il ya des changements considérables qui
sont déjà en cours des métiers qui vont
disparaître d'autres qui vont apparaître
on ne connaît pas encore et évidemment
il faut se préparer on a
les gaffes et les bété x qui qui sont
qui prennent de l'ampleur et nous en
europe il faut qu'on réfléchisse à des
alternatives pour faire contrepoids
alors l'institut beaucoup d'études il ya
notamment une étude que vous venez de
publier sur l'éventuelle taxation des
gaffes et on en reparlera avec vous tout
à l'heure stéphane bon sens ça va bien
oui ça va ça vient
aubin ont réfléchi à la manière de nous
remplacer oui est-ce que des robots vont
pouvoir enseigner à votre entreprise oui
et mieux je crois mieux et est pour
moins cher
en attendant vous êtes de ce coup de
pouce à l'université de versailles saint
quentin et gens faire la joie ni on va
peut-être pouvoir en place et des
écrivains par des robots aussi il y en a
qu'on s'a pourrait bonne idée il ya déjà
les correcteurs d'orthographe qu'il faut
faire attention mais oui mais non la sq
en ce sens et ce au nez de plus facile
de trouver un
un auteur enfin de défaire un livre par
un robot que de faire corriger je pense
alors justement alors sud elle n'a pas
été écrit par un robot mais par deux
auteurs frédéric are not kill et pierre
bollon où ils sont mais ils sont mis à
deux il ya un belge frederiek ernotte
qui devient donc le parent avec la
patronne aucun rapport c'est dommage que
sinon je pense qu'on organise cette
publicité adaptation est tous sur scène
sur sûrement quel magnifique qui comme
des mouches et en même temps comme des
mouches est drôle c'est l'histoire de
deux jeunes filles
deux jeunes femmes dont l'une s'est fait
larguer par son faîte a été trahi par
son petit copain et donc elle veut elle
veut se venger des hommes et elles
montrent un une sorte de faux sites de
rencontres au début c'est juste un jeu
ce débat on va faire venir des mecs qui
vont être attirés par nous puis on va se
un peu se moquer d'eux et puis en fait
ça tourne très mal parce que il ya
quelqu'un qui voit ça d'un mauvais oeil
et et quelques prétendants qui finissent
par tomber comme des mouches et elles
finissent par s'en s'inquiétait vraiment
content qu'il ya un côté elle vaut mieux
rester avec elle c'est l'amour de 0
enfin la vengeance sur le net etc
c'est assez astucieux comme des mouches
frédéric ernotte et pierre boulot voilà
et le cardinal barbarin pour rien mais
qui était pour derrick six mois avec
sursis pour non dénonciation d'abus
sexuels le frapper il fait appel alors
c'est très intéressant parce qu'il va
poser ses valeurs sûres justement pas
proposé sa démission il ya le droit des
hommes si je peux le dire
et puis il ya le le droit canon enfin ou
en tout cas le droit de l'église puisque
il fait appel donc il ne reconnaît pas
sa culpabilité vis-à-vis des hommes et
en même temps il présente sa démission
au pape ce qui a priori contradictoire
non oui oui non parce que je sais c'est
vrai qu'à partir du moment où
ces cas de dire la messe semble dite
puisque tout le monde estime qu'il est
coupable jeudi à l'opinion publique
absolument tout le monde la justice bien
évidemment mais enfin se dire le
procureur n'avait rien à réclamer comme
peine vers 16 heures il a été beaucoup
plus condamner car acquisition qui n'en
étaient pas voilà alors après je sais
c'est plutôt excellent exemple quoi
plutôt oui puisque c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt honnête de sa part est assez
logique après on verra ce que ce que ce
que le pape décide mais je vois pas
comment il peut faire autrement que de
le proposer une démission celui ci c'est
un sujet que je ne maîtrise pas du tout
dernier au moins d'ouvrir un certain
nombre 8 ou 6 et a sérieusement comme à
là c'est vrai que l'église de rome en
prend quand même un tout petit peu pour
son grade depuis depuis quelques années
c'est à dire que des dossiers sorte de
tous les côtés et puis moi je trouve que
voilà c'est c'est peut-être une des
bonnes idées un des bons aspects pardon
delà de la transparence actuelle en
parler de l'époque 2.0 1x d'être un des
aspects qui est assez positif de la
transparence des aspects aussi négative
de la transparence bien entendu mais
entre l'étude et de le travail qu'a fait
fred martèle également plusieurs années
où il a été vraiment en immersion à rome
le jour livre avec son dire avec ses 600
pages qui sont qui sont assez assez
remarquable s'est remarquablement
fouillé entre le reportage le
documentaire qui sont si sûrs
arte oui la semaine dernière sur la
question des abus sexuels sur deux vit
sur les sur les soeurs sur les nomme
c'est vraiment il ya carrément presque
des réseaux de prostitution il ya
presque des réseaux trophiques en tout
cas il ya des choses qui sont établies
et qui sortent cette femme
moi j'ai déjà entendu ce matin
monseigneur barbarin va présenter de
nouveau parce qu'il l'avait oui derrière
président a déjà présenté sa démission
qui avait été refusée au début de la
sphère lui va présenter sa démission
mais ses avocats vont interjeter ont dit
plus interjeté vont faire appel donc sa
marque et une nuance qui n'a pas lieu
d'être
évidemment sur sur la condamnation est
d'autant plus forte en effet que le
parquet n'avait pas requis de peine et
surtout la première condamnation pour
des faits similaires avaient eu lieu en
2001 avec l'évêque de caen qui avait été
condamnée à trois mois avec sursis
la selle double ça n'est pas rien et de
surcroît l'évêque de caen était resté en
place pendant dix ans il ya donc il ya
une évolution
c'est vrai en 20 ans mais je crois qu'au
delà des faits ce qui leur reproche
fondamental qui est un reproche d'ordre
institutionnel c'est que depuis très
longtemps
la hiérarchie catholique savez j'avais
dire tout le monde savait mais je pense
qu'on ne se doutait pas du caractère
systémique il est très heureux de tout
cela donc fins et c'est un reproche qui
dépasse la seule personne du cardinal
barbarin et lui même l'avait dit
d'ailleurs lui c'est assez
maladroitement défendu alors jeu on en
parle dans tout à l'heure mais grâce à
dieu
ces faits sont la plupart des faits sont
prescrits mais est-ce qu'il amélie grâce
à dieu oui enfin c'était pouvant
atteindre c'est ça oui ça fait les frais
la plupart des faits sont prescrits
et puis d'autre part il a il l'a dit
tout de même qu' il y avait d'un côté
son devoir
son devoir civique son devoir d'homme
qui consistait à dénoncer et de l'autre
presque son devoir d'homme d'église qui
a consisté à combrit ou à essayer de
couvrir son institution il
il l'a formulée de manière de manière
relativement clair d'ailleurs il ya ce
dualisme n'ont en effet qu'est qui
existe entre le alors la braye
semblables où ils seront doublées quand
même au droit commun encore en
présentant sa démission
enfin il ya l'église se retrouve dans
une dans une contradiction entre le
temps long oui elle elle s'inscrit
forcément est là et la nécessité de
sauvegarder coûte que coûte
bien malheureusement d'institutions et
puis de temps court et long on le voit
aujourd'hui qui entend médiatique dans
lequel c'est la position de barbara est
totalement il exhibait totalement
intenable
on parlera d'ailleurs peut-être du
catholicisme et tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui en france sachant que le
cardinal barbarin
un peu comme les pics copa français a
pris des positions à ces réactionnaires
si je peux dire enfin c'est
conservatrice sur les sujets sociétaux
notamment sur la pma sur le mariage pour
tous etc
on en reparlera tout à l'heure mais vous
parliez sexualité et l'homosexualité et
c'est vrai que cette église qui était
donc c'est peut-être de sujets tout à
l'heure qui était assez en avance dans
les années 50 sur le plan sociétal sur
le plan et baisser un peu repliée sur
elle même dans les dernières années
vous parlez de grâce à dieu c'est le
film de françois ozon qui reprend donc
cette affaire jugée aliot qui est celle
du père prenne à qui est donc accusé qui
a été condamnée d'ailleurs lui pour des
actes pédophiles qui était beau que
censés être protégés par le cardinal
barbarin
je propose qu'on regarde la bande
annonce de ce film dont on parle après
parce que c'est intéressant sur le
rapport justement entre les créateurs et
puis le droit je m'appelle alexandre
guérin père de cinq enfants je découvre
il ya un mois par hasard que le père
prenne à est revenu sur la région de
lyon comme avant c'est pourquoi cet
homme s'occupe-t-il encore d'enfant
et samedi après-midi maintenait dans le
local photo de la paroisse il me disait
c'est notre secret je suis horrifié par
ce que l'on dit
enfin moi ce que j'attends c'est une
sanction de l'église à son encontre lui
être clair avec double paire brenna
restera toujours prêtre vous avez une
idée d'autres victimes qui pourraient
témoigner mais je suis sûr qu'il en
existe il y à une plainte qui a été
déposée contre eux prennent un
c'est pas moi de regarder encore et des
gosses je croyais qu'ils étaient morts
il va falloir faire quelque chose fort
et bien d'autres victimes j'attends
depuis toujours ce que je puisse le tout
raconté le moins 6 décembre
est ce que vous voulez porter plainte
contre bernard prénat je supporte plus
nous sommes confrontés à des ses anciens
et grâce à dieu tous ces faits sont
prescrits vous rendez compte de la
violence de ce que vous venez de dire
grâce à dieu ça veut dire heureusement
grâce à dieu tous ces faits sont
prescrits c'était la parole du cardinal
barbarin
c'est un film qui retrace le lin et sow
c'est le combat d'une association la
parole libérée qui étaient d'anciens
scouts et guillon qui accuse le père
prenne à d'avoir abusé d'eux quand il
était mineur le père très nette des
condamnés il ya une autre
un autre personnage qui s'appelle régine
mère qui était mis en cause dans le film
qu'elle a été relaxée
le problème c'est qu'on a là alors c'est
un film qui est sorti avant que l
affaire soit examinée par les par le
tribunal et il y a évidemment au conflit
entre deux principes importants qui est
celui de la présomption d'innocence
et puis le principe de la liberté de
création
la liberté d'expression je ne vois pas
du tout où le conflit parce que ce qui
est plus important c'est quand même la
présomption d'innocence et la liberté de
création c'est mais c'est merveilleux
mais personne n'a jamais empêché
quiconque de faire un film aux on
pouvait tout à fait faire un film en
changeant les noms tout le monde aurait
reconnu de qui il s'agissait et il n'y
avait pas d'atteinte à cette présomption
d'innocence mais là en mettant
clairement le nom du prêtre le nom de
cette femme qui a d'ailleurs été relaxé
et serra c'est un scandale absolu c'est
à dire que on jette en pâture des gens
qui n'ont pas été jugées alors même si
on peut avoir à titre personnel la
certitude qu'ils sont coupables
sur le principe c'est indéfendable et et
quand on pense que la justice a osé
sortir comme argument pour autoriser la
sortie du film économiquement c'était
compliqué de pas de sortir version wii
en dix ans et économiques dans le
village fiction d'accueil si la cgt
oui il faut rappeler qu'en effet que le
père prenne à et madame madame maires
ont demandé le report du film après
après le procès et la justice a laissé
le film sur tille et ses films sortis en
disant muet et économiquement si
économiquement on peut pas ne pas le
sortir alors si maintenant c'est
l'économie qui qui décide de sa voix de
est qui qui vaut plus que la présomption
d'innocence qui me paraissait être un
droit en plus on parle sous votre
contrôle de surat me fasse apparaître un
endroit extrêmement important donc
facile
c'est honteux comme pour les fonctions
du cerami qu'elle était dans ses terres
que il y avait il y avait au fond 3 3 3
principes d'égalé valeur à concilier jeu
rien aux chroniques bah oui il y avait
enfin mais vous les avez énoncés il y
avait d'un côté la présomption
d'innocence de l'autre la liberté de
création qui est l'une des modalités de
la liberté d'expression et il y avait
les global mans les libertés économiques
c'est à dire que la la liberté dont on
dispose en france depuis 1789 91 de
pouvoir dans un contexte d'économie non
non non dirigiste si vous voulez de
pouvoir exercer l'activité économique de
son choix dans des conditions à peu près
à peu près favorable ça c'est un
principe fort aussi et c'est ces trois
principes pour résumer ont une valeur
d'ordre constitutionnel sont situés tous
les traits plus haut dans la hiérarchie
de nos de nos règles de nos normes
donc il fallait que le juge des référés
du tgi paris concilie c3 c3 règles alors
le vous l'avez dit le point le plus
marquant dans cette affaire c'est que
alors c'était d'un côté une fiction mais
de l'autre avec les patronymes qui
correspondait exactement à la réalité
des choses et en cela on peut dire en
effet que la fin du moins de mon point
de vue pas seulement de mon point de vue
mais là que la présomption d'innocence a
été a été bafouée et il faut rappeler
que la présomption d'innocence perdure
jusqu'à l'intervention d'une décision
définitive c'est à dire que
fondamentalement elle est encore en jeu
en cours aujourd'hui
malgré la condamnation le cardinal
barbarin est encore présumé innocent
puisqu'il a interjeté appel et prennent
à l'entraînement je sais pas s'ils
interjettent appel
il est encore présumé innocent viii la
cohésion n'est pas définitive
finalement c'est alors en tant que
créateur et et que directeur des thermes
vous pouvez être confronté à ce genre de
choses oui on peut être confronté à ce
genre de choses et on le sera
certainement rire et dans l'est dans les
lycées mais d'après moi je pense que la
liberté création s'inscrit aussi dans un
cadre qui est juridiquement j'ai une
formation juridique
donc je peux pas aller contre un des
principes fondamentaux et mais je trouve
qu'il ya une grande ambiguïté dans la
dans l'ordre on parle pas de l'aspect
esthétique du film est une grande
ambiguïté dans la position de lauzon
quand il parle d'une fiction issus de
faits réels
effectivement ce qui concerne prénat
voilà tout le monde est au courant de
ses clients reprochés il a reconnu
lui-même une grande partie des faits pas
la totalité
bon moi ça me gêne pas particulièrement
mais l'ambiguïté de françois ozon c'est
que une partie des noms sont les noms
réels on va dire de ceux qui sont
accusés
en revanche les examinateurs ce ne sont
pas soit trouvé en leur nom
sur l'île peut jouer à la fois sur les
sur les deux tableaux si c'est une
fiction pourquoi est-ce qu'on garde les
noms voilà c'est que appartements ou des
fictions bon pour est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure on pourrait prendre des
pseudos ouais tout le monde verrez de
quoi il s'agit mais au fond une fiction
sur rail slr joseph staline soucis mais
sur une fiction sur des faits
historiques secours et va s'entretenir
et moi ça me ferait une vraie question
même si je n'ai absolument aucune mais
là aucune sympathie pour pour pour le
père prieur mai mais je trouve qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est très le droit
n'empêche pas de deux du 10è de frais
non heureusement visiblement tout ce qui
n'est pas interdit est permis
ça s'appelle le reconnaît plus dans les
livres de politique fiction on peut tuer
le le vrai président du sénat celui au
delà des décisions
enfin moi ce qui me semble c'est que
c'est finalement une décision qui est
confessionnelles parce qu'on parle de
questions économiques mais finalement ça
me paraît plutôt fin par rapport aux
victimes on se dit bon il a reconnu une
partie des faits c'est probablement pour
les victimes
une grande victoire moi si cette ça me
ça me tourner le vent lui ce juste
devant l'extrême je trouve ça très
difficile
en plus on a eu récemment l'aller et
chatou ils attendent rehab est ce qu'on
va rectifier extraordinaire le théâtre
qui était c'était d'abord une
spectaculaire et le film est très très
bien mais c'était c'était mais bon des
sujets tellement dur moi je peux plus là
je suis à la limite de ce que je suis
capable de supporter sur la question de
la pédophilie est là puisqu'on parlait
de nos réelles il ya une autre affaire
qui a dû vous passionner qu'est ce que
c'est un collègue un coup oui un éminent
l'éminente collègue et ami guy
professeur de droit public à toulouse
qui avait été accusée d'avoir tué sa
femme il ya les deux procès il a été
acquitté par une première cour d'assises
il a pris de changer d'avocat après
dupond-moretti pour le deuxième procès
il était à nouveau acquitté il ya un
film qui sort qui s'appelle qui est
sorti il ya quelques semaines qui
s'appelle une intime conviction qui de
antoine rimbaud est alors dans lequel
l'amant et alors ils pas accuser
proprement niveau fait il est chargé
assez fortement
il l'a encore avec les vrais noms des
protagonistes
même s'il y a là encore un personnage
qui est qui est joué par une feuille ce
qui est totalement un personnage de
fiction pour regarder aussi cette bande
annonce
c'est à dire un très bon film m c'est
moi qui vous ai contactés pour que la
sphère viguier
je prends une affaire je commence par
lire le dossier je vous parle d'une
erreur judiciaire là vous êtes qui or
chez une amie de la famille de 150
heures en écoute téléphonique avant de
dire je suis emmerdé les personnes qui
connaissent la faire comme vous
c'est vrai madame qu'il ya de nouvelles
écoutes téléphoniques au dossier ah bon
en faisant penser quoi vraiment persuadé
les culpabiliser guinandé morte à ma
classe je vais le harceler
gerard piqué les rumeurs qui courent
t'as pas le droit de faire ça j'ai pas
le droit de faire quoi vous m'avez menti
je peux vous faire confiance
faites moi confiance et une dernière
fois
[Musique]
autre affaire où récente évidemment
alors l'est l'a été pour le cou
définitivement jugées puisqu'elle était
acquitté deux fois par deux cours
d'assises différentes mais dans laquelle
on donne les noms des vrais
protagonistes
ça pose quand même un petit problème
quoi une fiction quand on quand on est
sur des mois la question que je me pose
dans la ferme précédentes c'est dans
quelle mesure est ce que ce filou est ce
que l'atmosphère puisque vous parliez de
de jugement qu'on pense qu'on
compassionnel a pu avoir une influence
sur les sur les juges
oui dans quelle mesure les juges sont
ils soumis à une pression sociétale une
pression médiatique
dans quelle mesure ça peut influencer
leur logement moi c'est ça qui me pose
une vraie une vraie question
sont-ils en dehors de toute pression ou
pas je ne sais pas ce qu'il y'a pas un
c'est une sorte de délai de viduité
attend qu'il faudrait entre autres le
moment où la fiction son pare d'une
affaire peut-être je sais pas rebelle
sans que ce soit évidemment on peut pas
réglementé ça après on a en a une
culture pas dans votre sens c'est vrai
que j'ai l'impression que l'opinion
publique est de plus en plus oppressante
et que ça doit être très compliqué pour
la justice que la sphère sauvage par
exemple c'est cette somme avec comique
quand même été condamné à deux reprises
et sous la pression d'opinions publiques
et les gracier pas que l'opinion
publique a jugé télé c'était ça va il
faut rappeler une bonne cure
la tension qui brident tuer qui a tué
son mari
d'autres tout aussi nous voilà condamné
une première fois après les condamner
une deuxième fois deux fois qu'on a dit
oui avec avec des procès qui n'ont pas
duré deux minutes qui ont été
extrêmement long avec des tonnes de
pièces etc
les jurés la justice estime que et après
un débat l'opinion publique et les
médias y ait un téléfilm là un téléfilm
elle ruine qu'une campagne de presse une
campagne de lush sur l'opinion publique
absolument démente et ben peu importe
les décisions de justice on gracie cette
femme à mon sens dans ce cas là ça peut
largement s'expliquer c'est à dire que
pas un juge injuste qui ne peut pas ne
pas condamner cette personne qui a
commis un homicide avec préméditation je
crois que c'est le cas c'était avec
préméditation
ça c'est un fait et rien n'excuse un
homicide avec préméditation pas vraiment
d'accord maintenant il ya une autre
situation qui est la situation va lui
femme qui a été battue et pendant des
années et des années et là comment
est-ce que se positionne leur a été
gracié par deux grâce justice et il ya
une grâce partielle d'abord un gramme
par la suite donc là c'est tout dit et
tout à coup à mon sens un respect la
grâce et un respect de la décision de
justice la justice a passé voilà et en
dehors
ensuite c'est une décision qui politique
ce qui est politique et qui est aussi
l'homme et qui sociétale moi je crois
qu'il y avait une grande presse d'une
grande logique dans cette danse est
grasse qui fait suite à
une décision de justice mais c'est vrai
que c'est à dire que la justice
aujourd'hui peut-être moins que va faire
encore plus qu'autrefois et est allé
couteau fonds de la société valait
lourdes peut-être pas les juges
proprement dit mais les décisions
judiciaires c'est vrai je pense les
magistrats ne sont pas en principe sous
pression non mais juge dans un contexte
est juste dans un contexte il est
peut-être plus fort aujourd'hui avec
voilà les médias qui sont par des
affaires que qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya
cinq ans dans mes mains ont pour pour
pour l' affaire viguier enfin la
conviction face quitte ce qui est
choquant encore une fois c'est en effet
que les vrai patronyme soul sont même
temps file
oui parce qu'elles rendent un droit à
l'oubli aussi et oui et de surcroît tout
contrôle a été acquitté deux fois deux
fois par deux par deux cours d'assises
et de surcroît là il ya on oublie aussi
on l'oubli parfois le la puissance du
doute
il y avait des doutes
c'est vrai que le dossier était lourd et
c'est vrai que jacques viguier
mon collègue jacques viguier je le dis
vraiment avec gravité parce que c'est
quelqu'un moi que j'ai croisé deux ou
trois fois et qui dans notre nom notre
petit village universitaire du droit
public toujours eu la réputation d'un
collègue très brillant et ses écrits
sont très était parce que moi
aujourd'hui nous aujourd'hui
probablement détruit cette affaire l'a
complètement détruit mais il écrivait
des choses extrêmement puissante et
brillante jacques viguier il y avait des
légendes d'ailleurs sur qui courait sur
lui qu'ils considéraient que c'est
l'agrégation de droit public il ya cette
fameuse leçon en 24 heures que notre
meetic et on dit jacques viguier est
arrivé c'est une leçon de 45 minutes
qu'on prépare 24 heures en 24 heures
avant et jacques viguier est arrivé avec
le plan de sa leçon de 24 heures sur un
ticket de métro
et donc il a des gens il paraît que
c'est vrai je n'ai jamais demandé
c'est vrai que c'est pour vous il était
brillant oui mais voilà il y avait doute
et c'est fort mal défendu après alexis
on essaie tous de beauté un peu il a
pris les gens de haut et c est même
étonnant oui oui enfin c'était plus une
affaire d'humanité
yabon ce matelas qui brûle comme par
hasard le lendemain dans la décharge le
foot et ses abords il met tous a marqué
l'existence de doutes et le doute
profite à l'accusé mais juste pour le
film est assez bien fait là dessus parce
que c'est justement une sorte de débat
entre le personnage de marina foïs qui
est un personnage à leur créer de toutes
pièces qui n'existe pas qui veut charger
l'amant et dupond moretti qui dit dans
c'est pas mon travail mois s'est montré
qu'un doute sur la culpabilité
éventuelle de mon client et donc nos
portes comme ça mais justement ce vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la question de
la liberté de création
c'est aussi la question de la place de
la place de l'artiste est ce que la
place de l'artiste mais ça il ya autant
de visions qu'il ya d'individus la place
de l'artiste est elle celle de dénoncer
d'accuser avec certitude bien de poser
des questions mais moi mon camp et
d'autres opposants travailler sur
travailler sur le sur le doute est pour
moi le travail d'artistes est justement
de nous mettre dans une situation de
toute cette affaire je pense que le
le l'individu le spectateur est capable
de se faire sans jugement à partir
d'éléments et quand cette quand quand on
part sur une accusation pure et simple
surtout sur des affaires qui sont en
cours moi ça me pose toujours ça
toujours la vrai problème est grave dit
on et nous parle à une époque où les
intellectuels les artistes étaient
plutôt soit sur la défense des gens que
sur la cotation et là on ne sorte de
basculement way kéké quasiment je pense
qu'on peut le dater avec marguerite
duras l affaire villemin
quant à elle c'était la première fois
qu'un bail de l'intégrer coupable
forcément coupable à cette femme qui
avait rien demandé et mallet et que l'on
soit capable de la libération la une de
tous les journaux et elle prend de l
attaque quelqu'un est depuis ce moment
là en fait c'était assez malade parce
qu'elle l'attaqué en faisant semblant de
prendre sa défense
c'était dur à ce titre était quand même
terrible et cooper sens et non pas
forcément coupable jeudi pour se relever
d'une au travail il faut une filiale et
est depuis ce moment là on a
l'impression que beaucoup
d'intellectuels ou de défendre ce
attaque
est-ce que c'est leur rôle je suis je
suis pas sûr mais voilà oui c'est un
délai loin dans les oiseaux là n'ont pas
forcément des artistes comment des
intellectuels n'étant pas forcément de
la prison et la verse et techniquement
beaucoup pour faire le lien avec le avec
ce dont on va parler tout à l'heure vous
savez que pierre desproges aimait
beaucoup les les restaurants étoilés et
on lui présentait souvent le livre d'or
de l'établissement à la fin du repas et
en lille mettait en règle générale le
mot suivant je mets bien régalé et est
signée marguerite
je crois que l'europe avec jean
d'ormesson
[Rires]
mais c'était des projets devrait on
parler de 2,2 grâce à dieu de de barbara
il ya un livre qui a fait la une du
point qu'un livre d'inde species de
sondages qu'ils auront fort qu est l
ifop et qui s'appelle l'archipel
français et alors c'est pas du tout un
livre polémique ce livre qui reprend des
des chiffres et qui monte quand même une
évolution absolument incroyable de la
société française il y parle notamment
des prénoms en 1900 il y avait 20 % des
fils après marie aujourd'hui l'essence
0,3 pour cent et en même temps le nombre
de prénoms qui origine arabe peu près 18
près de 20% aujourd'hui 18%
ça montre alors une évolution de la
société française ça montre une puisque
on en parlait tout à l'heure une perte
de l' influence notamment de des racines
chrétiennes notamment catholique
d'où peut-être la plus grande facilité à
avoir des réformes que le mariage comme
le mariage pour tous dans le cardinal
barbarin disait que c'était un porte est
ouverte à la polygamie je crois comme la
pma comme ces frappes ont quand même
c'est cette évolution puis c'est
extrêmement frappant ce que beaucoup de
gens enfin le
le subodorer en tout cas mais comme les
statistiques sont interdites ethniques
sont interdites france sorte de
couverture la marmite et puis là c'est
plus une statistique c'était sont des
faits alors du coup je sais pas au point
de vue du droit comment on peut faire la
différence exactement entre les deux
tout fout le camp
maintenant non mais moi je suis ravi
mais ce qui est amusant c'est que tout
le monde a l'air de dire assez c'est
absolument étonnant etc
j'ajoute que 20% des femmes s'appelait
marie à l'époque les beaucoup d'hommes
qui s'appelait marie y voilà bien sûr
jean marie le pen lui-même comme
deuxième ou troisième prénom il y avait
13 ans une famille marie est très
important mais non mais c'était oui
c'est qu'ils étaient la trace de
l'origine voilà chrétienne et catholique
juif il ya énormément de vue et non
qu'ils sont d'origine tu devrais ils
n'ont pas de régime cathodique non mais
alors c'est vrai et alors il ya des
lials et les chiffres aussi sur le poids
de l'église catholique je crois qu'il ya
6 % je crois d eau maintenant qu'ils
vont te dire que c'est infini minorité
les aides sont bi cathodique
il ya quelques années fourques a l'air
de dire que c'est la fin quoi presque du
catholicisme faut prendre non pas
exagéré parce que il ya 6 %
effectivement mais mais il faut aussi
reconnaître que il est tout à fait de
bon ton et de tout à fait très bien de
dire qu'on va à la mosquée ou qu'on va
dans tel ou tel lieu de culte quelqu'un
qui sont un plateau de télé 10 va la
messe tout de suite il est catalogué on
dit oulala ça c'était assez dangereux
donc il ya sinon c est qu il ya des
produits qui est impossible c'est
impossible à dire enfin dans un débat
accattoli qui va à la messe à défendre
la tête de liste
radio courtoisie les politiques parce
qu'il ya aussi un retour de la religion
en politique on le voit avec notamment
françois bieber mais il ya une perte de
campagne d'influencé catholique on le
dit tout à l'heure avec peut-être des
positions qui sont un peu refermée quand
même ces derniers temps de 2,2 des
instances catholiques se pose par les
carnets d'alba main qui parlait de
polygamie verte à la polygamie avec le
mariage pour tous c'est vrai que
sociétalement l'église s'est refermée
mais mais ce que dit ce que dit le pape
aujourd'hui c'est que lui ce dont on
parlait tout à l'heure lui sans sa
position n'est pas de se mettre
forcément au goût du jour c'est à dire
que même si sa position est beaucoup
plus progressiste que celle des papes
précédent quoique ratzinger était
certainement beaucoup plus progressistes
comme on le pensait et qui ne laissait
qui ne le montrait même si sa position
et progressiste et même si dans son
intime conviction il peut être ouvert au
mariage pour tous je pense que il prend
tout simplement le temps d'avancé
d'avancer ses billes et sa position sur
des sujets sociétaux sur des sujets
politiques sur des sujets écologiques
économiques et quand même
révolutionnaire quasiment
révolutionnaire tout aussi bien pour la
curie romaine que par rapport à ces par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs
donc moi j'ai une certaine confiance
dans ceux dont ce nouveau pape et dans
l'évolution des positions de l'église à
part que l'église est dans une telle
situation
aujourd'hui que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres choses à beaucoup
d'autres choses à régler une escale qui
va rater un tournant c'est bien parti
politique l'église de rome face à paris
le temps le temps de l'église n'est pas
le temps médiatique rappelé mai mais est
ce que parce que justement il ya
peut-être un besoin
peut-être aujourd'hui aussi un besoin de
spiritualité ou le sang dans le dans la
société tout économique de toute
consommation ça ne s'appelait pas tout
le monde
il ya peut-être d'autres religions qui
prennent la place et mais justement je
vous le dis tout à fait justement il ya
d'autres religions qui prennent la place
et quels sont les religions qui prennent
cette place et des religions qui ont des
règles mais absolument extrêmement
attentif on peut pas dit oui ce sera
jeudi dans des bâtiments tno très très
honnêtement je pense que l'islam est
probablement plus en développement en
france que les évangélistes
oui bien sûr on est jeune et en
l'évangéliste ben voyons pas le débat
mais parce qu'il ya la question des
notamment et surtout du financement des
lieux de culte se pose pour ces deux
religions pour l'islam en premier lieu
et pour les évangélistes en second lieu
qui ne disposent pas de suffisamment de
lieux de culte pour se poursuivre mais
ne ne réduisons pas aussi puisque c'est
c'est quand même une vocation
universelle là dedans
dans cette affaire il ya l'église de
france d'un côté mais regardez
l'extension du catholicisme romain en
afrique en amérique du sud l influence
extrêmement nord il faudrait parler des
rapports de l'église avec l'occident 1
avec l'occident mais c'est vraiment vous
le disiez moi ça ne va pas d'entendre
ses positions très conservatrices je me
dis que ces gens là enfin entre
guillemets font leur boulot
moi je les attends pas ailleurs je
n'attends pas de l'église catholique
qu'elle vienne proclamer haut et fort
qu'elle est très favorable au mariage
pour tous ça s'appelle le plu raconte
divorcé et catholiques on peut avoir
subi une interruption de grossesse et
être croyante
oui il paraît si vous voulez moi je
pense que l'est ça peut se discuter
comment je pense précisément que
alors on peut on peut lui accorder plus
ou moins d'importance mais que
précisément la laïcité puisque la
laïcité règle quand même les liens entre
la puissance publique et les religions
et puis l'espace social permet un
pluralisme philosophiques idéologiques
de s'exprimer et que la critique des
religions la critique des dogmes
religieux est libre et pourvu que cela
dure et il faut critiquer les religions
parce que sinon on en oublie qu'on a le
droit de le faire et puis et puis les
religions tout à fait le droit de
critiquer les athées les agnostiques etc
les mécréants tout on veut critiquer par
le 10 mai et admettre la réciprocité
donc moi ça ne me choque pas chacun de
la sonas dire qu'aujourd'hui si la
religion la grande région c'est plus le
catholicisme
c'est sans doute la laïcité mais curieux
de ne tirer comme conclusion de ce livre
que vous nous dites que 20% des prénoms
sont des prénoms d'origine arabe ou
musulmane est la conclusion c'est oui le
catholicisme les temps est en baisse on
peut aussi en tire la conclusion que
l'islam est en hausse surtout pas une
once apparaît plus d'enfants oui on va
dire des visites que que la société par
la société bouge tout simplement et que
les influences sur le déclin de l'empiré
des conséquences politiques
on peut les on les voit c'est bien c'est
dire que face à une situation de deux
mouvements de d'ébranlement comme ça il
ya deux possibilités il ya ceux qui
disent il faut se refermer qui se
referme sur eux mêmes
et puis il ya ceux qui disent bon ben
voilà la société bouge et on peut on
peut construire quelque chose avec
société qui bouge et on voit bien que le
clivage politique il est bien là dessus
aujourd'hui on peut on peut aussi être
entre les deux nous ne pas être
catastrophé mai mais simplement accepter
d'idée en disant bah oui oui c'est que
c'est de savoir que la salle était enfin
c'est quand même un fait et c'est
peut-être on devrait beaucoup plus
réfléchir plutôt que de dire non non
c'est pas vrai mais non il n'y a pas de
l'ours et ce sans aller dans des
des théories un peu fumeuse mais c'est
vrai que tous ces gens qui ne donne plus
de prénoms français d'origine
en tout cas n'appelle plus leurs enfants
marie etc
mais les appelle plutôt de deux noms à
consonance étrangère c'est quand même un
fait important c'est un signe de 2 d'un
certain refus de de quelque chose d'une
acceptation de deux fondent dans la
masse etc
voilà c'est on peut pas on peut pas nier
ça c'est pas être réactionnaire c'est
être réactionnaire de le lire c'est
parfois laxiste prénom on a vu la botte
des kevin à l'époque de questeur et oui
et c'est la fin peut alléguer ville où
l'américain que les gens s'appellerait
kevin à propos de kevin costner s'est
pas les papiers d'une personne
je pense que c'est plutôt d'aider des
séries un peu plus bas de gamme que les
fils de kevin costner et lyon il y avait
des y avait des statistiques et j'ai
sorti là dessus le nombre d'enfants qui
s'appelait kevin dans l'année qui a
sorti oui
brandon ce qui est menacée et jordan
politique s'appelle jordan ou pour venir
oui alors pour ça je trouve ça dommage
que moi je pense qu'il ya maintenant un
sauvage est interrogé là-dessus parce
que oui je disais quand même le
l'affaiblissement du poids de l'église
permet aussi de da d'aider des réformes
sociétales de passe les démarches pour
tous il ya aussi toutes les mesures sur
la procréation
oui moi j'aimerais bien effectivement
qui est un petit peu plus de discussion
et de débat serein sur le sujet moi j'ai
fait une gpa pour pour avoir ma fille et
il faut préciser aux protestations pro
avec donc une
une femme porteuse pas en france puisque
c'est parfaitement illégal en france
donc j'ai recours aux états unis et
finalement on parle beaucoup de location
d'un ventre moi j'ai été insultée
copieusement sur les réseaux sociaux
finalement la majorité des gens ne
savent pas ce que c'est une gpa donc ça
je m'en suis quand même aperçu j'ai fait
beaucoup de pédagogie autour de moi pour
voilà c'est j'ai utilisé mes ovocytes
c'est mon enfant biologique
malheureusement j'ai un problème
mécanique cardiaque qui m'empêche de
porter mon propre enfant
après il ya effectivement tout le monde
n'a pas les moyens d'aller faire une gpa
éthique aux états unis ou au canada et
il y à des abus dans des pays qui sont
effroyables en inde par exemple où les
femmes sont parqués dans des fermes
c'est des femmes qui n'ont pas
d'éducation qui sont souvent obligés par
leur mari de faire une gpa qui touche
2000 euros pour la totalité de la
grossesse et qui surtout n'ayant pas les
connaissances de basiques en biologie ne
comprennent pas vraiment ce qu'elles
sont en train de faire donc c'est je
pense très dur et psychologiquement il
ya aucun suivi évidemment donc ça c'est
des excès malheureusement en eux en
n'autorisant pas la tva en france
ce qu'on est en train faire c'est qu'on
est en train d'oublier entre l'isi mais
certaines personnes à qui n'ont pas les
moyens aller dans des pays où les gp n
est pas du tout éthique voilà moi je
serai le vaudou dedans c'est que face à
un problème comme ça on a de soi on
l'interdît et ça ouvre la porte à un
marché qui est pas très recommandable ou
alors on l'a règlemente le monde sait
qu'il vaudrait mieux réglementer pour
absolument elisabeth badinter avait
avait écrit un article était fabuleux où
elle explique qu'elle était pour une gpa
éthique en france alors où il n'y a pas
de rémunération la femme porteuse ont
évidemment il ya un un dédommagement
parce que bon
la grossesse c'est pas anodin pendant
neuf mois c'est quand même c'est très
lourd donc c'est évident que 1000 femmes
doit être dédommagés mais la génétique
c'est ce que j'ai vécu mois aux etats
unis
et c'était une expérience qui je crois a
été aussi enrichissante pour la femme
porteuse que pour moi bon tu m'avais
interrogé tout à l'heure sur le fait que
les femmes porteuses ne s'exprimait pas
beaucoup moi la mienne elle serait ravie
de s'exprimer évidemment ne parle
qu'anglais
donc elle va pas s'exprimer en france
aux états unis elle l'a fait elle a
répondu à des journalistes
et elle explique que c'est une la plus
belle chose qu'elle ait fait sa vie elle
est très très fier de l'avoir fait parce
que je ne pouvais pas porter enfant
parce qu'on est devenus très amis
ça a été un processus très long avant le
début de la grossesse et elle a des
photos de ma fille dans sa maison elle
l'a pas fait parce qu'elle avait besoin
d'argent elle et son mari ont chacun des
jobs c'était vraiment une réalisation
personnelle et c'est une grande fierté
et elle a refait ensuite pour un couple
homosexuel dans deux ou trois ans après
voilà et donc on est encore en contact
sont sans voix des photos nos enfants
respectifs
donc pour moi c'était une expérience qui
était très belle très enrichissante
et puis surtout j'ai une petite fille
merveilleuse donc voilà quel est ce que
de celle des arbitres au fond même s'il
ya évidemment de questions d'argent
oui c'est pas la motivation alors encore
une fois c'est passé la seleccion
deuxième m'a parlé de ça ici quelqu'un
en avait parlé aussi qu'il y ait eu
recours à la gpa dès qu'il y avait le
même nom s'était pas alors la même
vision coup aux états unis on passe par
des agents si j'ai bien suivi
psychologique qui est très sérieux des
femmes porteuses c'est des femmes qui
sont mariés qui ont déjà leurs enfants
nous n'importe qui peut pas être un
porteuse et surtout on a il ya une
grande différence qu'il ya eu une
histoire qui a fait grand bruit dans les
années 80 d'une femme porteuse qui
finalement avait voulu garder l'enfant
savez est épouvantable sauf qu'à
l'époque les femmes porteuses était
également les donneuses d'ovocytes peau
quand la femme et la mère intentionnelle
n'était pas en mesure de donner ses
propres de vos titres moi j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir donner mes propres au
site
c'est mon enfant biologique mais on
avait recours aux ovocytes de la femme
porte et qui maintenant ne se fait plus
du tout sauf si c'est dans la même
famille mais c'est très rare parce
qu'évidemment là pour le coup elle donne
son propre enfant c'est un déchirement
mais ma femme porteuse elle a considéré
qu'elle était
qu'elle portait pour moi cet enfant elle
était une fois à utiliser le mot nounou
elle m'a appelé en me disant tu as chine
encore empêcher de dormir cette nuit la
mer c'est moi ma mère intentionnelle
c'est moi et il ya eu des moments qui
ont été difficiles aux états unis à la
fin de la grossesse ou elle été félicité
par des amis qui n'était pas au courant
et qui touchait son ventre qui disent
assez merveilleux
tu vas être une maman formidable et à
les repousser gentiment disant mon nom
sophie et la mer et je suis je porte son
enfant près finalement de grandes
explications sont à la baisse après
c'est vrai qu'il ya enfin l'une des
remarques copé ou d'aider des
contradictions qu'on peut vous porter
c'est que pour l'instant c'est vrai que
c'est ce que vous appelez gpa éthique et
les réserver à des gens qui ont des
moyens
c'est extrêmement coûteux paradoxalement
c'est pas de rémunérer leur importe qui
est coûteux ça c'est pas cool du tout
c'est pour moi je considère que c'est un
dédommagement sait même pas
c'est même pas un salaire ce qui coûte
très cher c'est les avocats les agences
les médecins aux etats-unis nous en
parle même pas les prélèvements de vos
sites dans mon cas en belgique et donc
des voyages dans tous les sens
c'est extrêmement c'est très très
compliqué et c'est extrêmement cher
versus allait le faire en inde ou 5 août
15 bourg merci pour ce témoignage non
après je pense
un problème tout à fait personnel je
trouve ça très bien après je peux
également entendre qu'ils aient des
arguments des jeux de ce qu'ils
sont lorsqu'on s'est dit satisfait
vraiment clean mais qui est qu'on peut
entendre c'est que voilà on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord on n'est pas
obligé d'insulter on ebd et puis
j'entends alors après j'entendais mieux
avant de le faire maintenant que c'est
fait fatalement je vois là je vais pas
choisi et je suis très contente mais je
sais très intéressant d'en discuter
alors après quand j'ai été jugé un peu
violemment je me suis quand même permis
de dire à des personnes de mon entourage
qui ont beaucoup d'enfants et qui m'ont
dit que c'était la volonté de dieu que
je n'aimerais pas que j'ai accepté
d'être jugés par un jury mais perd c'est
à dire mettez en face de moi des femmes
qui n'ont pas réussi à lasbordes avoir
d'enfant on peut essayer pendant dix ans
j'accepte d'écouter l'opinion et de la
prendre en compte mais je n'accepte pas
que des personnes qui ne sont pas dans
ma situation mais dans la vie mais
surtout aussi brutale en se permettant
de juger ma situation
feuilletons qui s'appelait pardon je
disais c'est le défi des passifs est
passé en entendant non non non oui c'est
bien ça très beau football et des
intérêts réels c'est l'amusement
je suis au théâtre le soir mais vous
êtes saisis à table sur piste puisque
c'est le thème des rencontres et une
cité qui auront lieu du 16 au 23 mars
notamment
au grand air de saint-andré pas que
n'est pas que pour la voix alors il ya
eu d'autres tellement il y avait eu
l'intelligence artificielle est venu le
temps pourquoi avoir choisi
la table parce qu'à chaque fois on prend
comme pour le temps le temps qui était
le pôle le thème delà des premières
rencontres c'est finalement là où
s'inscrivent absolument toutes nos
toutes nos vies la convergence enfin
humains demain l'aide à la saison
dernière c'était là la convergence entre
convergent l'humain et la convergence
technologique à table c'est notre
quotidien
en fait on essaie de prendre un thème
qui nous concerne tous dans notre
quotidien et de prendre un tout petit
peu de hauteur et quand il décortique et
de le démonter en fait l'idée c'est de
démonter en moteur on voit globalement
comment fonctionne le moteur mais on
aimerait bien l'analyser de façon plus
précise et en analysant de façon un tout
petit peu plus précise finalement change
sur ma vie sur et c'est assez
intéressante c'est parce qu'ils ne s'en
fassent ils aiment ça sans y réfléchir
je dérange c'est quand même ce qui nous
réunit les tous je sais que c'est que
nous mangeons manche de différentes de
différentes façons l'accueil dont l
évolution quand même non les sociologues
son dévolu sur mes dents dans quelle
mesure en fait ce que l'on entend quand
on questionne l'acte de manger quand on
questionne l'alimentation on essaie on
va essayer pendant ces rencontres
d'avoir une vision rappellera holistique
de l'alimentation manger c'est des
questions culte auguste hâtive c'est des
questions nutritionnelles mais c'est
également plein d'autres questions
comment la façon montant dont on mange
ce que l'on mange à une influence sur la
totalité de notre environnement et je ne
parle pas que d'écologie
je peux parler de social je peux parler
de culture je peux parler d'économie
etc etc c'est à dire que l'acte de
manger qui nous réunit tous à un impact
considérable sur notre environnement au
sens global du terme
donc je pense qu'il est important de ne
pas garder l'alimentation danse juste
son aspect nutritionnel et gustatif mais
de prendre un peu de hauteur sur le
sujet pour pour voir quelle quelle est
l'influencé de l'alimentation sur nos
vignes sur nos relations sur notre
planète
j'ai effectivement j'ai fait j'ai fait
une petite émission pour sur la cuisine
sans sel je n'avais pas de sel à cause
de mes problèmes cardiaques et c'est
vrai que bon je suis passionnée de
cuisine je trouve que le festival était
incroyablement complet je suis allé
regarder des différents les différents
tableaux et les différences mais c'est
si ça couvre absolument tout est à dire
que on ça va aussi bien de l'agriculture
intensive au bio aux réactions chimiques
qui provoque le goût enfin les cc c'est
incroyable ça m'a fait penser au livre
d'hervé this les secrets de la casserole
où il explique
oui elle est des vrais voilà les vrais
cours de chimie pour expliquer les
processus pourquoi y revient à 17h
chimiste de ce qu'on appelle la
gastronomie moléculaire exactement
exactement voilà suivi ensuite par
adrien de faire affaire adrien plus tôt
et les autres oui mais c'était et voilà
donc je trouve ça très intéressant parce
que vraiment très complet on a
l'impression que voilà c'est un travail
qui a été fait on sait sur sur tous les
thèmes vraiment ce genre de rencontre
absolument
et là il ya une dimension évidemment de
deux tables rondes avec des sociologues
avec des spécialistes et il ya une
dimension culturelle il ya des
spectacles parce que alors juste pour
revenir à ottawa le rendent là il est
très important aussi comme on l'avait
fait des années près des saisons
précédentes de dire qu' il ya différents
opinions autour de la autour de la table
et que l'on n'est jamais sûr une façon
d'asséner des arguments et des
certitudes c'est à dire que ces
rencontres une cité sont là aussi pour
instiller le doute dans nos certitudes
et en matière de d'alimentation on en a
un certain nombre
dans un point presse on raconte beaucoup
de choses et surtout de et surtout de
redonner au thème la complexité qu'il a
c'est à dire que moi quand j'entends des
débats sur le bio il suffit de passer au
bio mais non mais très bien moi j'ai 80
ou 90% de mon alimentation et bio c'est
très bien mais le passage au bio
ça pose un certain nombre de questions
et un certain nombre de questions
également sur l'avenir de la planète
c'est à dire est ce que et c'est une des
questions d'aidé dans les débats est ce
qu'on sera capable en 2050 de nourrir de
nourrir 10 milliards d'êtres humains en
bio on parlait de hervé this hervé this
tuiles à une réponse à ça et dit non non
on ne pourra pas d'où la cuisine note à
note en revanche il ya des avis
totalement divergent de celui d'hervé
this plus con c'est quand même c'est
qu'on devra probablement consommer moins
de viande non oui mais dégageront yens
sur un changement de la relation entre
entre les hommes les animaux sur le
bien-être animal qui un truc sans doute
sur alors c'est encore un peu bobo pour
l'instant mais puisqu'on parlait
spectacle vous avez assisté à un
spectacle avait assisté à financer dix
ans c'était une petite pièce de théâtre
qui était interprétée par vittorio
gassman et ugo tognazzi nous étions
trois journalistes que les deux derrière
en cuisine et savait deux confrères avec
moi et donc on était tous les cinq et
ils ont interprété cette pièce de
théâtre a duré à peu près deux heures
enfin le temps de vraiment de saison
démarrée vraiment le risotto quand on
est arrivé ça s'appelle il discutait
tous les deux en italien mais je pars
pas un mot d'italien de temps en temps
on arrive à comprendre de temps en temps
il nous parlait mais moi j'avais un peu
de mal le favier il y avait une certaine
interaction et c'était quand même
saisissant puisque enfin pour moi
c'était quand même 2 deux monstres du
théâtre et du cinéma c'était quand même
où il prenait le vent le rôle très à
coeur et le bien évidemment après on a
on a dégusté ce risotto qui était
vraiment délicieux voilà un fait si
c'est bien la clé non seulement il était
bon il est chargé de souvenirs en convoi
le le risotto c'était vraiment une
époque il ya l'option qu'il y ait
beaucoup de enfin peut-être plus de
l'expérimentation théâtrale comme ça au
restaurant aussi de se jouer sur les
deux côtés de la scène est restée la
patience mais les artistes se sont enfin
beaucoup d'artistes se sont intéressés à
cette question de l'alimentation de tous
temps il ya une il ya eu un pic il y à
il ya cinq six ans aujourd'hui il y en a
un tout petit peu moins mais voilà on a
quand même réussi à trouver trop quatre
spectacles et qui sont véritablement sur
cette thématique là c'est à dire comment
est ce qu'on arrive à corréler des
tables rondes et qu'il y avait des films
même des films avec des spectacles on va
dire que le spectacle vivant c'est notre
coeur de métier sans ses fins donc on va
à la recherche de ces de ces pièces
rares
il ne reste malheureusement trois
minutes donc on va pas pouvoir parler de
la taxation des gaffes à peut-être
puisque quand même y est mi mars pour
des femmes d'aujourd'hui de la femme
s'est alors il ya plusieurs problèmes
évidemment il ya le problème de la
violence et le problème de l'inégalité
et les premiers que de mick donc pour la
pauvreté aussi puisque les femmes sont
plus pauvres que les que les hommes
c'est important encore kebede journée
internationale de la femme et des droits
de la femme je suis partagé alors oui
parce que ça mais on met en avant des
interlocuteurs qui serait pas forcément
interrogé dans les médias
normalement après je pense que la gamme
des problèmes c'est important il faut
pas il faut pas que le combat de pointe
fasse oublier le combat de fond on a on
parle d'égalité de parité en entreprise
de plafond de verre mais à côté de ça on
a aussi long des femmes en france qui
peuvent pas se promener dans la rue sans
être insultées qui peuvent pas aller
dans les cafés donc j'ai eu une
conférence récemment où on parlait
d'excision et de plafond de verre donc
c'est c'est très très large
après on peut aller encore plus loin il
ya eu un article extraordinaire dans the
guardian qui est sorti à quelques jours
vous avez peut-être lui qui parle du
fait que toutes les dates à qu'on a en
fait l'humain par défaut c'est l'homme
donc les datas qu'on a cédé data sur les
sommes dont conseil
on sait exactement par exemple ce qui
provoque le cancer chez les ouvriers
parce que c'est des métiers qui sont
typiquement masculin par contre des
métiers qui sont considérés comme
typiquement féminin c'est à dire
manucure on espère des solvants toute la
journée aux impôts ménages
la zero donné on n'a rien du tout
ensuite le téléphone portable tout bête
c'est en théorie ce sont les femmes qui
sont les plus susceptibles d'acheter un
iphone l'iphone fait 14 cm en moyenne il
est calculé pour une main d'homme il est
impossible pour une femme de prendre une
photo avec une seule main pour un homme
bon et live demain syrie reconnaît à 70%
plus de chance la voix d or de la violer
des femmes
vous dites achiri alors aussi aux états
unis semant france en france je n'ai pas
testé je veux acheter du viagra ou je
cherche une prostituée siri vous réponds
vous lui demandez vous lui demandez je
cherche une clinique pour me faire
avorter comprends pas pourquoi préciser
que siri c'est l'assistant vocal de
l'iphone tout une femme ce qui est quand
même c'est quand même assez drôle c'est
une femme tout à fait elle a un sexe bah
elle parle syrien
le sexe c'est pas comme le gps qu'on
peut pas choisir et voilà qui nous rend
sur des choses plus sérieuses c'est
intéressant parce que c'est mais imposer
la vicodine arrivée c à l'ombre forme il
est vraiment le lire en entier sur les
voitures par exemple les tests les crash
tests qui sont faits par le rohan cap
sont faits avec des deux misé masculin
des deux miss des mannequins des
mannequins pardon sommes donc ils sont
basés sur la musculature des hommes
passionnés mais je faisais des femmes la
taille des hommes
et finalement les femmes ont 17 % de
chances en plus de mourir dans un
accident de voiture qu'un homme parce
que les calculs sont ces gens parce
qu'elles conduisent moins bien c'est
parce que l'émission est terminée
merci à tous merci des menaces et a donc
16 au 23 mars et une cité consacré à la
table celui de mclaughlin merci
infiniment vouriot réparé les dégâts
femme s'était pas de montceau et je
recherche de jonnhy merci beaucoup et à
très vite pour un nouveau of d'ailleurs
[Musique]